The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So, you have now 10
seconds, go ahead and click in
your answer.
OK.
We have a little bit of
a mixed response here.
So for those of you coming in
late, I'm going to give you a
second chance, and we say now
what if the p k a was 4.
Everything else is the same, but
the p k a is now 4 -- what
would the answer be?
OK, go ahead and click in your
response for a p k a of 4,
everything else being
the same.
OK, let's do 10 seconds.
Interesting.
More people got that right.
So it's the same answer for a
p k a of 3 as a p k a of 4,
but it gave people the
opportunity to think about
that a little more and see what
their neighbors had voted
and make a decision
based on that.
And so more people came up
with the right answer.
So let's consider now for a
minute why this is true.
So if you can switch to my
lecture notes, I have a couple
of slides on this that are not
in your handout but that are
related to things we've
talked about.
So just a brief sort of reminder
of where we were with
acid based titrations.
So, we last time talked about
what's happening at different
points of the p h curve, and
introduced this concept of 1/2
equivalence point where the p h
equals the p k a, where you
have equal number of moles of
molecules that are pronated as
depronated.
And another way to sort of think
about this whole thing
is that in the beginning at p
h's that are lower than the p
k a, you have more pronated
molecules.
And if p h is much above
the p k a, you have
more depronated molecules.
So, we can think about
things that way.
So let's think about the last
question that I asked where
are have a p k a of 4.
So, if you gave someone a sample
of molecules where the
p h was equal to the p k a of
the molecule, you'd be giving
them a sample where there would
be equal amounts of
pronated and depronated.
But instead, if you gave a
sample where the p h is much
above the p k a, then you're
going to be giving them a
sample that's mostly
depronated.
And I emphasize about using, in
terms of titrations, using
Henderson Hasselbalch for
buffer, but it also can be
applied to thinking about
this type of problem.
And so you can be thinking about
what sort of ratio are
you going to get of your
pronated to depronated when
you have given a particular p
k a and a particular p h.
And so, if the p h is really
very far above the p k a, then
you're going to be largely
depronated, and here's the
math for these two numbers.
If you're at a p h that's really
below the p k a, then
your molecules are going
to be pronated.
And so, you're going to be
thinking about this kind of
thing when you get to organic
chemistry, and also
biochemistry.
Biochemists spend a lot of time
thinking about the p k
a's of amino acid side chains,
and there are often mechanisms
that people propose of how an
enzyme works, and they're
proposing that some residue is
going to play a role as a
catalytic acid or a base
in an enzyme mechanism.
And often people are proposing
things that really just don't
make much sense in terms of the
p k a of that molecule,
that they're proposing, that
it's going to be giving off a
proton, but given the p h of
the enzyme in the body and
given the p k a, it wouldn't
be pronated.
So how is it going to give off
something it's not going to
have. So these are the kinds of
questions people talk about
in biochemistry, and if you're
in a biochemistry seminar and
someone's talking about
something like this, there
will probably be a hand go up in
the audience and say "What
do you think the p k a is of
that amino acid that you're
proposing that role in this
enzyme mechanism?" And there
have been people who are pretty
high profile who've
gotten themselves in trouble
over p k a issues.
So now, you should all be ready
to raise your hand in
those seminars and say "What do
you think the p k a is of
that residue?" So, you'll be
hearing about p k a's later,
and the thing that makes me
very excited is that some
other people who are taking
chemistry here, may not be as
aware of the sort of biological
role of p k a's.
Now you know something, you've
had some of these in your
problem-sets, and so when you go
into those advanced classes
and there's a discussion of p
k a, you'll raise your hand
and impress my colleagues
with your tremendous
knowledge of p k a's.
So I'm very excited
about that.
And please send me an email
when you get extra points
because of knowledge
of p k a's.
I want to collect that
information and use it for
evil purposes.
No.
But anyway, you can think about
p k a's of molecules
now, which will be very
handy to you later on.
So it's not just -- some people
tell me, if I promise
never to titrate a weak acid
with a strong base, do I have
to take that part of the test?
Well, you know it's not just
about acid based titrations.
Some of the things you learn in
that are actually relevant
to other things that most
of you will see
later in your career.
All right.
So, I love enzymes, enzymes are
great, I'm a biochemist.
Acid base is very important
in biochemistry.
And the other thing that is very
important in biochemistry
is oxidation reduction.
So, in these two units that
we're doing now that'll be on
the third exam, you're learning
a lot of the basic
principles that apply
to how enzymes work.
And so we started last time
talking about some rules.
Rules of assigning
oxidation number.
So this is sort of the very
basic knowledge that you need
to know to go on and do
oxidation reduction problems.
And here are those rules, and
now let's see look at some
examples of how we're going
to apply these rules.
So, first let's look at a
compound that has lithium and
oxygen in it.
All right.
What do I know about lithium's
oxidation number?
What's it going to be?
Plus 1.
So, things in group 1 are
going to be plus 1,
and I have 2 of them.
So we're going to be using
one of those rules up
there to assign it.
What about oxygen?
What's oxygen going to
be in this molecule?
Minus 2.
So it's not in a peroxide here,
so it'll be minus 2.
And then we have plus 2 minus
2 is equal to 0, and that's
good, because there's no charge
on this particular
molecule, so all of the
oxidation numbers
should add up to 0.
That's also one of our rules.
All right, so let's
look at p c l 5.
So, what we know about oxidation
number of chloride?
What are you guessing?
Minus 1.
What's the exception to that?
When it's with what?
When it's with oxygen
it can be different.
All right, so there's
5 of those.
I haven't told you anything
about phosphorous, but what
can you guess it's
going to be?
STUDENT: 5.
PROFESSOR: I love that
enthusiasm, good.
So, it will be 5, and so
overall, we're going
to add up to 0.
So you won't always have a rule
about everything in your
molecule, but you'll be given
something that you can get a
handle on and then predict
what the other
thing is going to be.
So let's do a couple more.
So, what about h n o 3?
So let's start with oxygen --
you told me about oxygen,
what's oxygen going
to be here?
STUDENT: Negative 2.
PROFESSOR: Negative 2 and
there's 3 of those.
And we need to have this
all add up to 0 again.
So, what about hydrogen?
STUDENT: Plus 1.
PROFESSOR: Plus 1.
What's the exception
to that rule?
When its with a metal.
So what does that leave
for nitrogen?
Plus 5.
And that will all add up.
All right, so you're very good
at this, so let's bring in
that clicker competition,
and you can tell
me about this molecule.
All right, 10 seconds.
Excellent -- not necessarily for
the competition since most
people got it right,
but I love seeing
people get it right.
So, 2 times plus 1 minus 2 is 0,
so we know our states here.
And I'll just tell you another
thing you can do in doing
these problems, if you recognize
that something is
often seen has a unit here, you
can also think about this
as h plus and n o 3 minus, and
you would get the same answers
to the problem.
So, if it's a little complicated
and you want to
break it apart, you can do that
too, you'll get the same
answers there.
All right, so as I said, in this
unit it's a lot of adding
and subtracting, so this part
is not too complicated, but
you just have to be paying
attention and doing your math,
simple math, correctly.
All right, so we looked
at some examples.
So now we're going to give
some definitions.
What is oxidation?
What happens when something
is oxidized?
Yup.
So, when you oxidize something,
electrons are lost.
What happens when you
reduce something?
STUDENT: Gain electrons.
PROFESSOR: You gain electrons.
Most people are good with
those definitions.
Here are some that give people
a little bit more trouble.
Oxidizing agent.
So it is an agent of oxidation,
so it accepts -- an
oxidation agent is something
that wants to oxidize
something else, so it
gets reduced itself.
So it's an agent of oxidation.
It runs around trying to oxidize
other things, but it
itself is going to get reduced,
and then you can
probably figure out what a
reducing agent is, it's an
agent of reduction.
And so it itself will
be oxidized.
It'll try to reduce
something else.
It'll run around trying to
reduce something, trying to
give off its electrons, donate
its electrons so that it can
be oxidized.
So, keep these definitions in
mind, because you're going to
be using them a lot
in this unit.
So now we're going to use them,
we're going to look at a
reaction, and we're going to
think about what's being
oxidized and what is
being reduced.
And this particular type of
reaction, a disproportionation
reaction, the same element can
be both oxidized and reduced.
So let's break this down
into two equations.
In every reaction there's going
to be an oxidation and a
reduction, and so you can
write those separately.
And poor sodium, sodium is
getting kind of a jip.
A lot in these last few units in
acid base, and here again,
it's a spectator ion here, so
it doesn't even make it into
the equation.
And it was ineffective as a
conjugate acid, it hasn't
really been doing very
much recently.
But that's OK.
All right, so let's look at
what's going on here and try
to figure out what's happening
in terms of what's being
reduced and what's
being oxidized.
So let's start over here, let's
think about what the
oxidation numbers are in this
particular molecule.
So what would be true about
oxygen here and chloride.
What do we know about this
combination of things in terms
of oxidation numbers?
So let's start with chloride,
what's that going to be here?
So, we have a minus 2 here.
And the whole thing is going to
be minus 1, and so what is
that about chloride?
Plus 1, right.
So this is one of
the exceptions.
Chloride is usually minus 1,
except when it's with oxygen,
and here we have an overall
charge of the molecule of
minus 1, so it all has to add
up to minus 1 and it does.
All right, so now let's
do that side.
So what's going on here?
Are they going to be similar
or different?
Let's start with the oxygen,
what's that going to be?
So we have three negative 2's.
It's not a peroxide, so it's
negative 2 for oxygen.
The overall has to be
equal to minus 1, so
what is chloride here?
Plus 5, right.
So that's unusual, but
that's what it is.
So we use our rules.
Chloride is usually minus 1,
except when it's with oxygen,
and then it can be something
different.
So, here chloride's going from
plus 1 to plus 5, so what's
happening to it?
Is it being oxidized
or reduced?
Yup.
So it's going from plus 1
to plus 5, so we have an
oxidation going on.
So to tell whether something
is an oxidation or not, you
need to figure out what the
oxidation numbers are and then
see what's changing in the
course of that reaction.
All right, so down here, we've
already done this one, so we
can put that down here.
So we have minus 2 for oxygen,
overall minus 1, and so
chloride is plus 1 again.
And what's the oxidation
number on the
other side for chlorine?
Minus 1.
I just have to look, and
so that's minus 1.
So here we're going from plus 1
to minus 1, so what is that?
That's a reduction.
And if we had figured out that
they're both oxidations and
something we would have done
incorrectly, because in these
reactions you're going to have
oxidations and reductions.
So, here, and this is
disproportionation.
So, you have chloride in one
state, and in another, it's
undergoing a reduction.
OK, so that's how you sort of
think about what's happening
in these types of reactions.
So now we need to balance
reactions.
And this is very important in
getting the correct answer to
the later problems, and so we'll
go through an example of
how you're going to balance.
You need to think about
whether it's an acidic
solution or basic solution,
and we'll talk
about that at the end.
So, first here, we can look at
the two 1/2 reactions going
on, we have iron, we have
chromium, and so we're going
to look at those separately.
So here is the first one, and
let's think about what's
happening over here.
So, what would our oxidation
number of the oxygen be here?
What is happening to it?
So, figure out what the
oxidation numbers are of the
chromium on one side, you know
what it is on the other side,
and then tell me what's
happening to it.
I hear some murmuring.
People in one recitation aren't
helping out people in
the other recitation, are they?
All right.
Do you need more times?
You good?
You clicked in?
Let's do 10 seconds.
OK.
People did pretty well
on that one.
Let's look at the
answer to that.
So, let's go back to
my Powerpoint.
And so, oxidation number for
oxygen here, minus 2.
The overall charge on
that is minus 2.
So you have to figure out what
the math equals there.
And so, if you run through the
math, then you see that you're
going from a plus 6
to a plus 3 state,
so we have a reduction.
OK, 75% did that,
got that, good.
So, most of you should be able
to get this one now, iron plus
2 to iron plus 3.
Just yell it out, what is that?
Yeah.
So here we have our oxidation.
Now let's balance this.
And I left some nice blanks in
your notes, but not so many
that you won't be able to keep
up and you should feel free to
yell out the answers and we'll
go through balancing this
pretty quickly.
So there's a couple of
different rules.
I'll just say some books have
things differently.
If you can get the right answer,
you can use whatever
procedure you want.
I have found in the past that
this particular procedure a
lot of people find to be the
easiest. So I'll teach you
this one, but you're free
to use whichever ones
work well for you.
All right, so the first thing
we want to do is balance all
elements that are not
oxygen or hydrogen.
To make it equal on both sides,
we're going to do
oxygen and hydrogen later.
But what do we need to do
up here to balance our
non-oxygens?
We need to add a what?
A 2.
So we need to add a 2 over here,
two chromiums here, two
on the other side.
What about for iron?
Nothing.
All right, so that was
pretty simple.
Now, in this procedure you add
water to balance the oxygens.
So, what are we going
to do up here.
How many waters do
we need to add?
So we need to add 7 waters.
And the bottom one, bottom one's
pretty easy so far, we
don't have to do anything.
So, go ahead and write
in your 7 waters.
Next step is we're going to
balance the hydrogens that we
just added, and we can balance
here with h plus, and I say
here's one place that
books are different.
Some of them balance in the
more sort of technically
correct way with hydroium ions,
but then your oxygens
get unbalanced again, so it's
OK to use the simpler
approach, and just balance
with h plus.
So how many h plusses
do we need to add to
balance the top part?
Yup, so we need to
add 14 over here.
Again, the bottom one,
nothing to do.
Pretty simple.
Now we need to balance the
charge, so we just added h
plusses, so we just added some
charge to this, and now we
have to balance the overall
charge, so you want the charge
on one side of the equation to
be equal to the charge on the
other side of the equation.
So how many electrons are we
going to have to add to this
top equation to balance
the charge?
I heard the answer.
6.
So we have to add 6.
I told you, this unit involves
adding and subtracting in your
head, and you always want to
check your work when you're
doing this on an exam, because
it's really sad when you lose
points for something that is
adding and subtracting.
So you want to make sure that
you don't lose points on these
on an exam.
So what about the bottom --
finally we get to do something
with the bottom one,
what do we do?
So, we add how many electrons?
1, right.
OK, so now our charge
is balanced.
So now, we want to multiply up
one of the 1/2 reactions so
that the electrons are going to
cancel, and so what do we
have to multiply by the bottom
equation so that the electrons
cancel with the first?
6.
So we have 6, 6, and 6.
And now, we're going to add
those together and make the
appropriate cancellations.
So here is our overall equation
-- we have the 6
electrons, the 14 protons, we
have our chromium oxide
compound, we have the 6 iron 2
plusses, on the other side,
the 2 chromium 3 plusses, the
7 waters, the 6 iron 3
plusses, and the 6 electrons.
So, we should be able to cancel
the electrons, so we
cancel those out.
And now we want to double
check that,
in fact, it's balanced.
Again, this is very important to
do on the test, it's really
easy to make some kind of math
mistake, but you should be
able to figure it out
at this point.
It won't be balanced if you've
made a math mistake.
So there should be 14 hydrogens
over here, 14 over
there, 2 chromiums, 2 chromiums,
you have 7 oxygens
here, 7 oxygens there,
6 irons, 6 irons.
And the charge also should be
balanced on both sides.
So you can double check
that and if it's
good, then you're done.
And this was in acidic solution,
so we should have
again this number and a charge
of plus 24 on each side,
double check, make sure
it's correct.
So, that was acidic solution
and we ended up with an
equation that had
h plusses in it.
You can also be asked to do it
in basic solution, and again,
books have different
approaches here.
What I like to do is the
simplest thing, which is to
use the same steps all the way
up to here to get your same
answer that you had for the
acidic solution, and then
neutralize it at this point.
So, adjust the p h in quotes
by adding hydroxide ions to
both sides, and so, if we have
14 h plusses here, we can add
14 o h's on one side, and 14 o
h minus on the other side.
And then we can add those
guys together.
So we have now 14 waters
over here.
And we have still our 7 waters
on this side, and then the 14
hydroxides on this side.
And now, we should be
able to cancel out
some of those waters.
So, we had 14 over here, 7 over
here, so we can just have
7 on this side.
And now we have an equation
that looks like
it's in basic solution.
So instead of having h plus,
which you would have in acid,
you have hydroxide for
basic solution.
So you can follow
the same rules.
Again, some books do
it differently.
I think this is the simplest way
to do it, the least likely
to make those kind of adding
and subtracting errors.
So those are sort of the
fundamentals you
need for this unit.
You need to figure out oxidation
numbers, looking at
the composition of a molecule,
and you need to be able to
balance equations.
When you can do that, you can
go on to do other things.
So, at this point -- oh, let me
just say, those are the two
answers there, so you can see
acid and then in base.
So, at this point then, I want
to try to do a little demo to
show you that when you do do
oxidation reduction reactions,
cool things can happen.
So, it's more exciting, perhaps,
in real life when
oxidation happens
than on paper.
So I'm going to turn it over
now to Dr. Taylor and Dr.
Patti Christie who's here to
help us with this demo.
And they will -- go for it.
PROFESSOR: OK, so this is mostly
visual, there's not too
much we'll need to say.
Basically what we're
going to do for
you is oxidize magnesium.
So we have a source of
oxidation, which is going to
be carbon dioxide, which is
dry ice, and what we put
inside the dry ice is
solid magnesium.
So we're going to set the
magnesium on fire, and then
put the oxidating agent on top
of it, and you can see the
rest of what's going
to happen there.
And you can actually also
determine if this is an
exothermic or an endothermic
reaction while you're at it.
[EXPERIMENTING]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Thanks
to my helpers.
All right.
So oxidation reduction reactions
can be quite
interesting, and don't
try that at home.
So, we're going to continue on
now, you know the basics and
we're going to talk about
electric chemical cells.
We're going to introduce
Faraday's law, and a thing I
love to do, is come back to my
friend Gibb's free energy.
So, thermodynamics is all over
the place in chemistry and you
can't get very far
away from it.
So hopefully, by the end of the
class today, we'll come
back to free energy.
All right, so what is an
electric chemical cell.
It's any device in which
electric current, which is a
flow of electrons through a
circuit, is either produced by
a spontaneous reaction, or
used to bring about a
non-spontaneous reaction.
And so a battery is technically
a collection of
cells in a series, so that the
voltage that each cell
produces is the sum, the battery
has the sum of the
voltages of each cell.
So, let's take a look at what
some of these might look like.
Here's a little cartoon
of a simple version.
We have a beaker --
2 beakers with different
solutions in them, 2
electrodes, a salt bridge
across, and as electrons
transfer through this, you can
read a current on an amp meter
here, you can read some kind
of voltage coming off.
And so, I like to talk about how
good you guys have it at
MIT with the Web and handouts
and everything and how
students in the old days at MIT,
if they're going to do
their problem-sets at night,
first they had to build a
battery to get electricity
to be able to see.
So you guys have it easy, you
have these electric lights and
all this fancy stuff now here.
So, let's sort of break apart
sort of a components.
Here is my beautiful picture
that I drew of this system,
that's why I show you a better
cartoon first. So this is a
beaker that you -- here's one
beaker with one solution on
this side, here is
the other beaker.
So we have two electrodes put
in, we have a salt bridge, and
then we have a wire across where
we can measure voltage.
So, let's think about what is
happening on each side.
So in one beaker you're going
to have an oxidation
reduction, and in the
other beaker you're
going to have a reduction.
So if we think about what's
happening over here, you could
have a zinc system, is
oxidized from zinc 0
to zinc plus 2.
And so, this is sort of a view
of what would be happening at
the electrode, you have zinc
solid or zinc 0, and you've
also have zinc plus
2 in solution.
And so, as you take a zinc solid
atom, going into zinc
plus 2, you can have an
oxidation reaction.
And here would be the
equation going down.
So zinc solid to zinc plus
2 with two electrons.
Those electrons can go through
to our other beaker on this
other side, and so here we have
a copper solid electrode
or a cathode in this case, and
we have copper plus 2 in
solution, which is being reduced
to copper solid, and
so we're plating on to our
electrode on this side.
And so, here we have the
reduction reaction, copper 2
with two electrons going
to copper solid.
So our oxidation is
happening at an
electrode called the anode.
The reduction is
happening in an
electrode called the cathode.
And as these reactions occur,
you're changing the charge on
either side.
So, you have this salt bridge,
and so to neutralize the
change in charge, you would have
negative ions come down
here, because we're producing
more plus 2.
And on the other side potassium
is going in as we're
going from copper plus 2 to
copper solid, again, to
balance this change in charge
that's occurring.
So those are the basic
components of a simple
electrochemical cell.
So, we could talk about the
cell -- here's some
nomenclature that represents
the cell.
So, the one that I just showed
you, you have one electrode, a
zinc solid, and we also have
zinc plus 2 in solution.
You have a single line between
the solid and the zinc plus 2
ions in solution, that indicates
there's a phase
boundary, so you're changing
phase from solid to aqueous.
Then if you see two little lines
that tells you, okay,
one part of the reaction's in
one beaker, the other part is
in the other beaker, that
represents the salt bridge
which separates out the
two 1/2 reactions.
And then on this side, we're
going from copper 2 in
solution, single line which
indicates the phase boundary,
to a copper solid over here.
So the amount of charge that
goes through the system, it
depends -- and how much of the
zinc that is consumed or the
copper that is deposited, is
proportional to that charge,
the number of electrons that
go through the system, and
this is called Faraday's law.
So let's look at what is
happening a little bit here,
so we have a little movie that
shows the oxidation reaction.
So in green is the electrode,
and then here are the water
molecules, and let's look
at what happens when
there's this oxidation.
So here things are floating
around, and
there go the electrons.
And this pops off into
solutions, so if this is zinc,
so then as this is happening,
we have a zinc plus 2 now,
it's aqueous.
There go electrons, we
have our oxidation.
Here comes off zinc plus 2
floating around, there's
another zinc plus 2 that
just came off.
And so our electrode here is
being consumed as this
oxidation occurs.
I think it's really cool, the
electrons, you can see them as
this green going along
in this movie.
So, this is a little thing to
think about what's happening.
So what's happening at the
cathode, we have a reduction.
So if we have our copper
ions are going to
plate onto our electrode.
So here in blue is the
electrode, and again the water
molecules, here's a little
copper 2 in solution.
And when it gets electrons and
gets reduced, it's going to
start plating, so let's
take a look at that.
So, here's -- oh, there
comes the electrons.
And so now it becomes part of
the electrode there, the
electrons come in, and so you're
building up, you're
adding, your plating on
to your electrode.
Now it got its electrons, it
got reduced, got reduced
again, and it becomes solid, and
plates onto the electrode.
And we see the electrons
coming in.
So again, the amount of current
that flows, the number
of electrons that flow are going
to be proportional to
the chemistry that's happening
at the two electrodes.
So you can figure out how much
zinc would be consumed, how
much of the zinc solid electrode
could be consumed,
and how much copper would be
deposited on the copper
electrode for a particular
amount of current.
So say we have 1 amp of current
for 1 hour, what are
we going to do to our system?
So we can calculate this out,
so we use this equation to
find out how much charge is
going to pass through the
system, we have this term q,
the magnitude of charge and
it's in Coulombs, those are our
units, and that's equal to
the current in amps, and just
for unit conversion, amps are
Coulombs per second, so that's
very convenient because we're
going to take the current and
times second, so times time.
And so if we work that out, we
had 1 amp and we had 1 hour,
so we're going to have 3,600
Coulombs that are our
magnitude of our charge.
So once we know that, we can
convert, using Faraday's
constant from charge into moles
of electrons that had to
pass through the system to
generate that kind of current.
And here is our friend Faraday's
constant, and so
that's in Coulombs per mole.
And so, we can we can convert
the number of Coulombs into
the number of moles of electrons
that were passed
through the system with
that amount of
current, 1 amp for 1 hour.
Now, how is this going to relate
to the zinc consumed or
the copper deposited?
So we know the total number
of moles that
passed through the system.
And so, then we have to think
about for every 1 mole of zinc
that was consumed, how many
moles of electrons went
through the system?
So why don't you yell
out and tell me what
you think that is.
What do you think?
2, right.
So we are going from zinc
solid to zinc plus 2.
So, we need to do -- to consume
one, we need two electrons.
So then we can look up the
atomic weight of zinc and
calculate the number of grams.
We can do the same
with copper.
So for one mole of copper
deposited, how many moles of
electrons needed to pass
through the system?
two, right.
And then we look up the atomic
weight, which is very similar,
and actually with significant
figures, it's the same amount,
which won't be true
for most things.
All right, so these problems
are not too complicated.
So let me just tell you a little
bit more about types of
electrodes that can be used.
It's not always true that you
have to use electrodes that
are going to be consumed
or have species
deposited on them.
You can use an inert electrode,
such as a platinum
electorate, and here is
an example of that.
So here, this cell has a
platinum electrode, and the
reaction that's happening, you
have actually two things in
solution instead of going from
a solid to a solution.
So this is just another example
of a type of cell.
So let's think about, then, what
equations we would write
for this chemistry and
what's going on.
So over here at the cathode,
what happens at a cathode,
oxidation or reduction?
I'm hearing somewhat
of a consensus.
That's correct.
Reduction.
That's the thing you're going to
need to memorize, it'll be
important in doing problems
later on.
So, what is the reduction
reaction that you imagine
would be happening if
you have copper plus
2 and copper solid?
So, if you're reducing it,
you're going to be reducing
copper plus 2 with two electrons
to copper solid.
So, same reaction
we saw before.
So what about over here.
This is the anode, which has the
oxidation reaction going
on, and what oxidation reaction
can you imagine
happening with chromium plus
3 and chromium plus 2.
What's going to what?
So, you're going from plus
2 to plus 3 with
one electron here.
So that would be the
oxidation reaction.
So let's think about how
we would actually
write this down then.
So the notation for this type of
cell, we're going to have a
platinum that indicates the
electrode, a single line that
indicates a phase boundary.
And in solution, you have the
chromium plus 2, chromium plus
3, those are both aqueous,
so they have a
comma between them.
So this is on one side in one of
the beakers, so that's the
reaction at the anode.
And then we have a bar here that
indicates a salt bridge.
And then in the other beaker, we
would have the copper plus
2 and the copper solid,
separated by a single line,
because there's a phase boundary
between the aqueous
and the solid.
And then here are our
two equations.
At the anode, we have
copper plus 2.
Aqueous going to copper
plus 3 aqueous in an
electron at the cathode.
We have copper plus 2 aqueous
and two electrons going to
copper solid.
So those are our two equations
and how we
would write that down.
Another example of an electrode
is a hydrogen electrode.
And this is very common.
In fact, most potential standard
reduction potentials,
or as they're also known,
oxidation reduction potentials
are measured against a standard
hydrogen electrode,
and it'll be abbreviated
s h e.
And so, if you see it was
measured against s h e, you
will now know what that means.
So that's a standard
hydrogen electrode.
So there's a couple of
different variations.
It can be used at the cathode
or at the anode.
And so, if you're using it
at the cathode, h plus is
reduced, and at the anode,
h 2 is oxidized.
And often you have a platinum
system there as well, for the
standard hydrogen, so platinum
is commonly used in a standard
hydrogen electrode.
So, let's just sort of look at
a little picture of this.
So here, we may have like a
glass cylinder here, we're
pumping in h 2 gas.
And here you can see it
sort of bubbling down.
We may have a solution of
hydrochloric acid, which would
have a lot of h plus in it,
and so this would be a
hydrogen electrode on one side,
the other side may have
something more common or
something that we saw before
with the zinc solid and
the zinc in solution.
So since on this side we have
the cathode, of we can write
about the h plus aqueous, a bar
for the phase transition
to h 2 gas, and then we indicate
that there's also a
platinum electrode
going on here.
And the other side is what we
saw before, the zinc solid and
the zinc plus 2.
So you're just introducing
different types of electrodes
that you may be seeing in
this particular unit.
And again, you want to remember
what reaction's going
on at the cathode,
and at the anode.
All right, so just very briefly,
I will mention cell
potential, which has many
different names -- cell
voltage, EMF it's
often called.
And so the flow of electrons
generates a potential
difference between the
electrodes in the current.
And this can be related back
to our friend, delta g.
So in this equation you have
this potential difference
that's generated by the flow
of the electrons, and that
times Faraday's constant times
the number moles of electrons,
and if you have a negative sign
here, that's equal to the
free energy of the cell.
So we can relate that back.
And a little bit
of information.
We have the standard
terms as well.
We can have the delta e nought,
the cell potential,
cell voltage, you'll see
many names for this.
And that's when the products
and reactants are in their
standard states.
The units we're talking about
here are in volts, sometimes
you'll see things reported
in millivolts as well.
And let's end with one final
clicker question, and then we
can announce our clicker
winner for today.
OK, 10 seconds.
Most people should
get this right.